sie ist philosophin und eine
preisgekrönte reporterin carolin emcke
immer wieder reist sie in kriegsgebiete
und spricht mit menschen die alles
verloren haben um von grund auf neu
anfangen müssen und genau das ist heute
mein thema der neubeginn der aufbruch
denn rund ums neue jahr fragen die uns
wohl alle
wie geht das eigentlich mit dem neu
anfangen was tun wenn die vorsätze vom
januar bereits im februar makulatur sind
und was wenn ihr zum neuanfang gezwungen
werden
herzlich willkommen im neuen jahr und
herzlich willkommen auch ihnen frau in
vielen dank der jahreswechsel vmk
bedeutete ihnen etwas also der übergang
vom 31
dezember zum ersten januar eigentlich
nicht ich find auch meistens das
westernfest ein bisschen komisch aber
natürlich die idee des neuanfangs ist
schön
wir haben die aber natürlich bei ganz
anderen ritualen im verlauf des jahres
auch und nicht nur beim sozusagen neuen
jahr
geburtstag wie zb geburtstage zwei
spieler ich hatte jetzt eher an so etwas
gedacht wie also einer bestimmten
hinsicht natürlich erntedank oder also
frühjahr also es gibt natürlich schon
die neuanfänge die uns die jahreszeiten
ermöglichen oder diktieren
natürlich haben wir religiöse form das
einerseits natürlich dass sich besinnen
uns auf eigene fehler oder versäumnisse
oder sünden also je nachdem wie man
glaubt und darin natürlich wirkt sich
auch immer die hoffnung einer bestimmten
reinigung und der möglichkeit dass man
wieder neu anfangen kann und dass einem
vergeben würde
also insofern es gibt ganz viele formen
glaube ich die uns überliefert wurden in
denen die idee des neuanfangs steckt
beginnen sie selber also in
unterschiedlich nicht mehr so religiösen
formen würde ich sagen ich glaube die
stärkste empfindung von religiosität
habe ich über musik man sagt ja auch man
ist religiös musikalisch sozusagen also
ich würde sagen ich bin metaphysisch
gebettet in und durch musik und sonst
gibt es eher rieten die jetzt aber gar
nicht stark religiös aufgeladen sind
also ich gehe auch weihnachten und
ostern aber nicht mehr so wie das
vielleicht die kirche keine hätte viele
leute machen sich ja vorsätze zum neuen
jahr
kennen sie so was nicht vorsetzen aber
ehrlich gesagt habe ich natürlich jeden
tag ärgere ich mich über mich selber und
jeden tag fällt mir irgendetwas ein bei
dem ich denke das könntest du jetzt
endlich mal lernen oder darin besser
werden oder so ich verbinde das jetzt
nicht so stark mit dem ersten januar
aber natürlich das gefühl dass man mit
sich hadert das habe ich ja etwas was
wir uns verraten könnten was sie gerne
ändern werden
ja da gibt es natürlich sachen die haben
mit der also es gibt sachen die ich mit
der arbeit zu tun
ich weiß nicht ob das andere so geht
aber zum beispiel ich verbessere immer
an eigenen texten die passagen die schon
gut sind
naja also hätte man die stelle sagt die
fehlt mir endlich so ganz gut und dann
könnte man es so ein bisschen besser
machen oder so und man weiß genau welche
sachen nicht funktionieren und man mal
weißt genau bei dem argument die fehlt
was und das schließt noch nicht richtig
zunächst passagen kriegt es dann
trotzdem auch wenn man drauf schaut
nicht unbedingt besser und da macht man
sich natürlich ein bisschen leicht mit
sich selbst also das ist ja etwas
kleines professionell ist aber das ist
was wo ich mich immer über mich selber
ärger denke das könnte man jetzt mal
lernen
naja ihre kolumnen in der süddeutschen
zeitung sehen ja ein großer erfolg sehr
gut von wegen er kann so falsch nicht
sein die hat man es natürlich also da
ist es eher so dass man sich selbst
verzeiht wenn man eine nicht so gut
gelingt war natürlich ein wöchentlicher
rhythmus einfach sehr viel wie sind
daneben auch nicht gleich gut das muss
man dann glaube ich ich musste ja mal
ein theaterstück denken von max frisch
dass ich sehr mag das heißt geografie
ein spiel
und daran gibt es eigentlich nur der
hannes kürmann ein wissenschaftler der
vermasselt eigentlich sein leben und
sagt an einem bestimmten punkt den ich
nur noch einmal neu anfangen könnte und
dann tritt der registrator aus was ihnen
gottes figur und gibt ihm die
möglichkeit neu anzufangen und er geht
schlüsselstellen seines lebens durch und
versucht die neu zu gestalten und taucht
immer wieder in die gleichen fallen
würde gerne mit ihnen zusammen eine
szene angucken auf 7 theaterstück da
versucht der hannes kürmann seine frau
sozusagen zwar kennen zu lernen aber
dann eben doch nicht zu seiner frau zu
machen sondern sie wieder loszuwerden
eigentlich wollte ich nur noch einmal
ihre alte spiel gehören spielern
faszinierende figuren die immer ihre
gleichen gesten machen immer ist die
sehr gewaltsam an weiß es trotzdem ist
man gespannt jedes mal ich weiß ziemlich
womit kann ich sonst nach denen ist
leider kein muslim mehr da
das macht nicht um 8 uhr komplett ist
haben meine haushälterin stoppt das
können wir nicht sagen
kommen sie eine junge dame um zwei uhr
nachts in ihre wohnung schon denken sie
daran dass um acht uhr morgens ihre
haushälterin kommen können wir nochmals
anfangen
von anfang an erbitten wie ihm beliebt
es ist zwei uhr ja gut aber keine frau
sehr gut ich erwarte einen jungen
ich erwarte einen jüngel nun sagen sie
nicht gleich zweimal als glaubten sie
selbst nicht dran und sagen sie nicht
jüngling so reden die uneingeweihten
sagen sie ein student der schach spielt
ein junger mann hochbegabt das genügt
hat es geklappt
das habe ich nichts gehört hoffentlich
ist ihm nichts zugestoßen
gut ich mache mir jeder noch zusätzliche
sorgen dass keine einzige zigarette mehr
ein student wissen sie aber hochbegabt
leider ist er von einer krankhaften
eifersucht wenn er kommt und findet eine
frau in meiner wohnung um zwei uhr
nachts erst im januar schießt nicht
übertreiben wohin sizilianern aber blond
wissen sie mit blauen augen und das
kommt von den normannen hingegen sein
mund ist griechisch ein musikalisches
wunderkind ein urenkel pirandellos jetzt
reden sie zuviel hoffentlich ist ihm
nichts zugestoßen weil sie nicht anrufen
wo haben sie noch eine zigarette
nehmen sie meine pfeife und sie es ist
ein leichter tabak early morning peilt
er was ich gesagt habe vorschnell bleibt
natürlich unter uns sie verstehen die
universität weiß nichts davon
sie müssen ziehen langsam und regelmäßig
johannes kühn mannschaft nicht dass er
wird dann trotzdem mit dieser frau
zusammen sein und das stück sitzung
wissen wir die these dass sie eben
eigentlich gar nicht so richtig was
ändern können stimmt das
das muss erst mal drüber nachdenken also
das eine ist natürlich die frage ob das
individuell was ändern können als ob wir
uns als personen verändern verbessern
erweitern können oder wie politisch
sozusagen gesellschaftlichen was
gesprächen geht es erst einmal unsere
leben
bei individuellen leben würde ich sagen
also zunächst mal wirklich sagen will
wenn wir auf unser leben schauen
verringern sich die möglichkeiten mit
dem eltern werden also ich würde denken
wenn man 15 ist oder 20 ist kann man ja
noch in ganz ganz vielen möglichkeiten
denken wie man leben möchte mit wem man
leben möchte was für was man studieren
möchte was von beruf man ergreifen
möchte und ich würd mal sagen ich bin
jetzt 47 würde sagen ein paar
möglichkeiten gibt es jetzt wirklich
nicht ph also insofern ist haben sich
jetzt auch also ich könnte jetzt
vermutlich außer adoptieren könnte ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich keine kinder mehr
kriegen und auch adoptieren wäre jetzt
vielleicht nicht mehr so ganz einfach
und ich vermute ist würde mich jetzt
auch niemand mehr als etwas einstellen
wofür ich sozusagen eine lange
berufserfahrung in bestimmten bereich
bräuchte also ich glaube insofern ist
einer bestimmten hinsicht dass
älterwerden beschränkt glaube ich
bestimmte möglichkeiten aber das heißt
nicht dass man nicht trotzdem noch sich
verändern oder etwas neues anfangen
könnte also ich finde zum beispiel das
älterwerden
gleichzeitig erweitern sich die
möglichkeiten wenn man genau versteht
wonach man sich sehnt oder was man
braucht das ich also ich würde zunächst
sagen das älterwerden ist ein moment
oder eine phase
indem man präziser spüren kann was die
eigenen bedürftigkeit 'nen sind und
daraus glaube ich entstehen dann
wiederum freiheits räume also man macht
nicht mehr so viel dieselben fehler
schon ein bisschen gefunden wie man dass
man hat sich ein bisschen gefunden
man traut sich jetzt auch eher nein zu
sagen bei dingen von denen man weiß dass
man nicht wirklich richtig eigentlich
lust dazu hat also das glaube ich ist
ein gewinn aber die frage die sie
stellen ist ja nicht nur ob man
sozusagen mehr man selbst wird sondern
ob man noch jemand anderes werden könnte
also sie fragen ja es stimmt wenn man so
sätze sagt wie wenn nicht nur noch
einmal neu anfangen könnte oder wenn ich
die chance hätte das nochmals
entscheiden und der subtexte ich ja
immer dann würde ich sagen was aber
denken sie das naja also der nicht
gesagt auch den eindruck ich bin
ziemlich versöhnt mit meinem leben aber
man hört doch solche sätze sehr oft also
oder glauben sie dass es jemand nur so
daher gesagt das weiß ich nicht aber
wenn sie mich jetzt fragen würden würde
ich jetzt ganz gerne noch mal 20 jahre
zurück oder würde mir etwas einfallen
was ich ganz anders machen würde weiß
ich gar nicht weil man natürlich sich
fragt hier bekomme ich denn die
fähigkeiten mitgeliefert etwas anders zu
machen
das ist wahrscheinlich genau jenen
dangel punkt ein stück weit wer wer bin
ich die dann anders handeln wir genau
also die frage ist müsste ich eine
andere person sozusagen zu geschenkt
bekommen
zu der neuen zeit eines neuanfangs
das heißt ja nicht dass man nicht glaubt
dass man sich dass man noch etwas wagen
kann also ich finde das schöne bei der
bei dem bei dem imaginieren eines
neuanfangs oder bei den fantasien die
damit entstehen ist ja nicht nur dass
man sozusagen sich negativ korrigiert
also ist ja nicht so dass man sagt die
und die viele hoffe ich würde ich nicht
noch einmal begehen sondern es hat ja
auch was davon dass man
ja sich neue möglichkeiten für sich
selbst wünscht in einem anderen umfeld
in einem anderen kontext und das ist
auch interessant das aussteiger etwas
sehr faszinierend das an sich haben weil
dies eben waren weil die dann einfach
gehen und die türen schließen es gibt
zum beispiel eine boxerin auf srf auf
und davon heißt die hat immer sehr hohe
quoten hohen erfolg und das sind einfach
geschichten über personen die sagen das
war's ich beginne ganz neu auf den
bahamas beispielsweise warum fasziniert
und ich glaube das eine ist hatten einen
abenteuerroman aspekt also man schaut
dass auch an weil das wort in crussow
haft es hat ich glaube natürlich sind
das ja so sekundär leben also man geht
da so ein bisschen mit und malt sich das
aus kurioserweise also die meist ich
weiß gar nicht ob das dieselben folgen
sind die wir dann schauen aber die male
die es geschafft ich fand es merkwürdig
deprimierend weil ich da immer das
gefühl so viel neuanfang ist dann ja
auch gar nicht sondern es ist halt ein
anderes setting drumherum aber natürlich
trägt man ganz ganz viel von dem was
einen konditioniert hat was eingeprägt
hat was rituale sind mit sich ich habe
eine mutter die in argentinien
aufgewachsen ist und die sehr spät erst
dann nach europa und dann nach
deutschland gekommen ist und ich bin als
kind eben in deutschland aufgewachsen
und obgleich dann meine mutter schon
sehr viele jahre und jahrzehnte in
deutschland lebte ist sie beispielsweise
im sommer immer auf der schattenseite
der straße gelaufen und ich lief immer
auf der sonnenseite der straße also es
gibt dinge die würde kein südländer
würde in der sonnenseite laufen in samoa
und das heißt es war so ein beispiel an
dem man eben erkennen konnte
ja sie lebte dann in deutschland um sie
lebt in europa aber die prägung und das
was zu hause gewesen war war eben doch
mitgewandert das ist ja vielleicht auch
ein bisschen dass er nicht an den mit
den vorsätzen zu neujahr dass man merkt
man kann sich die natürlich machen aber
wenn man die vorsätze so wählt das die
nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun haben
mit der person die man ist dann werden
die zwangsläufig scheitern ja ich glaube
also bei den bei den vorsätzen oder das
sind ja zwei sachen also die vorsätze
sind hier man nimmt sich etwas sozusagen
regelhaft es vor und wahrscheinlich
misslingt es schon deswegen weil man
irgendetwas konsequent anwenden will und
alle anderen dinge im leben macht man
auch nicht besonders konsequent
sozusagen bei der idee des neuanfangs
die mir gut gefällt sozusagen ist das
was ich vorhin ansprache also das was
uns eher religiös überliefert ist also
dass man sich selber auch verzeihen was
vorher misslungen ist oder worin man
nicht gut genug war oder wo man schuld
auf sich geladen hat also ich glaube das
was ich schön finde an der vorstellung
vom neuanfang ist dass man tatsächlich
auch diese last des haderns mit sich
auch die last von alten verwundungen
oder von alten verletzungen versucht
hinter sich zu lassen und zu sagen ich
will nicht dass das mich alleine
beschränkt oder oder belastet oder
dominiert und den teil diese dieses sich
auch zuzutrauen und den mut zu haben
mit einer hoffnung in etwas neues hinein
zu gehen auch wenn die vergangenheit für
diese hoffnung eigentlich gar nicht
genug gründe liefert den teil des des
neuanfangs also deren vorgriff ist ja
der auch sowas im tropisches hat ein
bisschen gute vorsätze ja nicht gute
vorsätze sind ja eher kritisch gedacht
sozusagen also diesen anderen aspekt ist
genau also diesen anderen aspekt des
neuanfangs den der wenn man so will
schöpferisch ist der gefällt mir sehr
gut
also auch etwas geduldiges mit sich
selbst etwas geduldiges
und etwas ja auch daran zu glauben und
zu hoffen dass man anders könnte mir
könnte dass es mehr räume und
möglichkeiten gibt als man sich
vielleicht manchmal sieht sie selber
haben ja schon in ihrem leben immer
wieder wenden vollzogen als wenn man
ihre biografie anschaut sie haben
philosophie studiert beispielen personen
bei habermas da schien aber in hopp
haben dann ihre dissertation geschrieben
bei axel honneth und gleichzeitig wurden
sie dann aber auch reporterin beim
spiegel sie haben ganz viele
kriegsgebiete bereits die waren im
kosovo sie waren im irak sie waren in
gaza vielen anderen orten was hat für
sie damals den ausschlag gegeben war so
eine art neuanfang oder ist das
harmonisch ineinander über geflossen
ja ich glaube nachträglich legt man sie
ist natürlich immer etwas rationaler zu
recht als es dann so war ich würde gar
nicht unbedingt sagen dass es immer
große wendungen waren sondern für mich
hat die ganze arbeit in kriegsgebieten
sehr sehr viel zu tun gehabt mit den
philosophischen fragen die mich als ja
studentin der philosophie umgetrieben
haben ich hatte natürlich
gerechtigkeitsfragen macht mich ganz
ganz stark immer schon schon als
schülerin und dann aber eben auch als
studentin umgetrieben also wirklich
umgetrieben und natürlich reist man ja
nicht ohne dass wie man sozialisiert
worden ist das eine blöde formulierung
sondern ich reise natürlich auch wenn
ich in kriegsgebieten bin als diejenige
die diese texte gelesen hat und über
sein bestimmte fragen nachgedacht hat
und ich komme aus der tradition der
frankfurter schule das haben sie erwähnt
und das legt man nicht ab sondern würde
sagen wenn ich irgendetwas sozusagen
denke risch geprägt hat dann diese zeit
und diese fragen waren natürlich in den
in den kriegsgebieten von großer
relevanz das ist der zusammenhang von
gewalt traumatisierung und
sprachlosigkeit was ist es eigentlich
für eine aufgabe mit menschen zu
sprechen die nicht vernünftig klingen
weil sie so traumatisiert sind und
insofern würde ich sagen es ist eher so
gewesen dass ich mit diesem
instrumentarium aus der philosophie in
den journalismus gegangen bin und dann
eben auf diesen reisen
ja man meine arbeit gemacht habe
sozusagen aber nicht als jemand anders
als die wii diese vorstellung
zurückzugehen ganz sinnlich philosophie
sie hatten ja auch lehrer regen den usa
dort liegt durchaus gut doch also dass
das würde ich schon sagen also ich würde
schon sagen das ist lange gehadert habe
damit wäre ich würde sagen immer wenn
ich in den eine akademie irgendwo war
fehlte mir das welt haltige und es
fehlten mir auch die sorte menschen die
man trifft wenn man auf reisen ist in
krisenregionen und immer wenn ich als
reporterin als journalistin arbeitet man
die theorie also so und ich würde sagen
das bücherschreiben ist dann
er einen weg gewesen indem ich sozusagen
beide bereiche stärker zusammenbringen
kann also dass ich das reisen und die
und die erfahrungen mit menschen in
anderen gegenden kombinieren kann mit
der eigenen reflexion und mama steht am
anfang eines neuanfangs auch das
begehren die sehnsucht gibt da dieses
schöne diktum von der nelly sachs der
jüdischen schriftstellerin gesagt habe
alles beginnt mit der sehnsucht und da
sind wir bei diesem buch von ihnen die
wir begehren ein buch in dem sie im
grunde genommen ihr coming-out schildern
und sie hat deutlich auch machen wie
viele dinge im leben eigentlich anfangen
mit dem begehren nicht mit einer
einsicht und auch vielleicht nicht mit
einem entschluss sondern mit dieser
sehnsucht mit dem begehren ist das dann
so ein wie soll ich sagen ein sehr
sinnlicher neuanfang der sich einstellt
und den mann erst im nachhinein eben aus
neuanfang verstehe ja das glaube ich
schon dass glaube ich eine schöne
beschreibung also ich glaube dass man
wenn man etwas begehrt das haben sie
jetzt ja auch so beschrieben und dass
ich etwas wünscht ich glaube manchmal
gerade in der in der pubertät also davon
handelt das buch ja zunächst ist das ja
so dass man eigentlich gefühlen
ausgeliefert ist wird immer noch gar
keine begriffe hat also man spürt etwas
aber man weiß gar nicht ganz genau was
das ist was man spürt ich glaube das
kennen wir übrigens ein echter werden
auch noch da haben wir vielleicht die
begriffe aber trotzdem können wir sie
manchmal nicht zu und man merkt man
fühlt sich unwohl oder etwas stimmt
nicht denn man ist unbehaglich in der
arbeit und insofern glaube ich gibt es
so ein spüren dass dem wirklichen
begreifen vorausgeht
ja und insofern ist das eine ganz schöne
form des neuanfangs wenn ich sagen würde
man wird in einer bestimmten hinsicht zu
etwas gedrängt oder man bekommt eine
richtung zu etwas ohne dass man jetzt
schon sagen kann es ist ein ziel oder
man hat sich etwas vorgenommen und ein
mann
ja das beschlossen oder so und das was
mich hier in dem bei dem buch besonders
interessierte war eben dass man aber um
sich etwas wünschen zu können oder um
das wünschen
präzise auch definieren zu können was
ist eigentlich ist was man sich wünscht
muss man wissen was es gibt also
soziologen sagen
es braucht skript braucht drehbücher
also wir müssen in einer bestimmten
hinsicht auch wissen dass man so jemand
sein kann oder dass man so etwas glauben
kann oder so lieben kann oder so leben
kann oder einen solchen beruf ergreifen
kann
was wissen sie denn an den
gesellschaftlichen gehen in
homosexualität vollkommen tabuisiert ist
keinen menschen gar nicht homosexuellen
werden
ich glaube es ist zumindest schwer das
zu infizieren was man empfindet es würde
ich ja also ist ja noch gar nicht so
also ich bin zwar schon 47 aber so lang
ist das jetzt auch nicht her dass ich
sozusagen jugendliche war und auch in
meiner jugend gab es praktisch keine es
wurde nicht über homosexualität
gesprochen
es gab in der schule es war sehr sehr
gut wunderbare lektüre mit der wir uns
befasst haben aber keine erzählte etwas
von dieser sorte von begehren und ich
glaube das macht es zumindest schwer das
zu identifizieren und würde mal sagen
homosexuelle mann wusste zwar dass es
das gab aber das war ungefähr so wie man
weiß dass es eine wüstenfeld maus gibt
man also man weiß die existierte man
trifft nie eine und insofern würde ich
schon sagen ja natürlich es ist
ausgesprochen schwer sich etwas zu
wünschen wenn man gar nicht weiß dass es
das als möglichkeit gibt um ist
sozusagen auch noch einen etwas anderen
bereichen über zu tragen ich glaube das
ist das was der große unterschied bei
den flugbewegungen ist die wir im moment
erleben im moment erleben wir eben auch
flucht vor etwas nämlich vor krieg und
vertreibung und verfolgter und vor
misshandlungen
wir erleben aber natürlich auch flucht
zu etwas hin weil auf einmal auch mehr
bilder existieren von dem
die ein leben sein könnte ich glaube es
gibt ganz andere möglichkeiten also über
das internet natürlich oder über filme
sich das glück auszumalen als das früher
gar das ist interessant dass sie machen
jetzt sozusagen den bogen vom bild das
man hart von etwas beispielsweise
homosexuelles leben dass das begehren
dann überhaupt sozusagen deine richtung
annina kann genau hin zu den
flüchtlingen sie sagen also die bilder
die die haben gibt ihnen auch ein grund
mehr tja gehen also ich sage dir mal ein
beispiel ich saß einmal sehr sehr sehr
unglücklichen situationen in medizin in
kolumbien in der küche einer familie die
uns bei einer straßenschlacht zwischen
ge und medea gerettet hatten die hatten
uns von der straße raus zu sich ins haus
gezogen damit wir aus dieser
gefahrenzone rauskam und wir saßen
mehrere stunden die wir eben nicht
rausgehen konnten weil es zu gefährlich
waren mit wildfremden menschen in deren
küche auf dem fußboden und hofften dass
die schießerei vorbei geht und dann fing
man eben an sich zu erzählen hast du
familie und und tun so und dann
irgendwann sagte diese frau zu mir in
der küche da wo du herkommst führt dann
nicht der staat krieg dauernd gegen die
eigenen leute dann habe ich gesagt nein
ja aber es war klar die kante 40 jahre
bürgerkrieg und für sie war
bürgerkrieg und eben eine staatliche
gewalt die absolute normalität und das
heißt ihre frage waren sie unterstellte
dieselbe und kommentiert von sich zu mir
und sie nahmen an das müsste überall so
sein und natürlich werden ja die
fähigkeit sich etwas zu wünschen oder
was präzises sich zu wünschen auch durch
solche gewaltregime oder
ja durch hunger oder durch not natürlich
auch eingeschränkt und ich glaube das
ist einerseits das traurige und
sozusagen das schwere und belastende und
im moment erleben wir glaube ich eben
eine historische zeit in der sich das
verändert durch die verfügbarkeit von
bildern die eben auch ja so wenn man so
will seinen kritischen impuls haben ja
bei denen man dann sagen kann ich will
dass auch ich will auch ich finde das
interessant weil sie eigentlich ja wie
auch sagen es ist gleich gar nicht so
sehr die idee der gerechtigkeit die
menschen los ziehen lässt
natürlich ist es oft auch schlicht
vertrieben werden
aber mal abgesehen davon nicht so sehr
die idee der gerechtigkeit sondern ein
begehren ja eigentlich sehnsucht danach
ich glaube für ganz ganz viele also wie
gesagt ich glaube der große flieht
wirklich erstmal weil sie gar nicht
anders können weil
weil fast bomben abgeworfen werden weil
die häuser zerstört werden weil es
keinen strom mehr gibt und und und aber
es gibt natürlich auch sehr viele
menschen die fliehen weil sie sagen ich
will nicht dass mein kind hier aufwächst
oder ich will dass mein kind hier nicht
stirbt und oder ich will dass mein kind
zur schule gehen darf also ich glaube
schon
es verbindet sich mit der flucht
natürlich erstmal ein wie gesagt an
wegwollen von etwas aber schon auch ein
hoffen auf etwas anderes und auch ein ja
in anspruch oder eine hoffnung auf ein
minimal würdiges leben das in den
umständen eben nicht gegeben ist und ich
glaube das ist ja etwas was jede mutter
und jeder vater auch glaube ich
nachempfinden kann mit dem lasst sie uns
an dieser stelle etwas gemeinsam
anschauen und zwar sicher einen
ausschnitt aus einem film mitgebracht
den ich ihnen gerne zeigen würde es ist
ein film von kurt pelda den ihr halt
gemacht hat gemeinsam mit andrea
pfalzgraf er hat eine syrische familie
begleitet von auf der flucht von syrien
bis in die schweiz und die familie ist
bereits in der schweiz und blickt noch
einmal zurück auf ihre stars auf bilder
oder saas und erzählt wie es war
aufzubrechen
das ist meine stadt saß hier bin ich
geboren hier habe ich meine frau fatima
kennengelernt
das ist die straße in der wir gelebt
haben wir mussten weg freiwillig hätte
ich das nie verlassen
das ist meine heimat hier habe ich
meinem mann geheiratet
hier sind meine kinder zur welt gekommen
ich wünsche mir dass es wieder so wird
wie früher als mädchen habe ich mir
gewünscht hübsche kinder und ein schönes
haus zu haben
auch dass die kinder eine gute
ausbildung bekommen aber es hat uns
nichts übrig gelassen
ich hoffe auch dass ich irgendwann
wieder zurückkehren kann nach syrien
nach asaz so gut wie die mehrheit der
syrischen bevölkerung war mit dem regime
von assad nicht zufrieden aber niemand
getraute sich darüber zu reden
es war ein horror das regime zu
kritisieren hätte ein todesurteil
bedeuten können
niemand ist nicht betroffen von syrien
ist nichts mehr übrig die kinder werden
heute geboren und morgen werden sie
getötet
alles ist kaputt es ist eine katastrophe
wir hatten einfach nicht das glück ein
normales leben zu führen
wir hatten nicht das glück ein normales
leben zu führen ist es eine frage des
glücks
also wenn glück sozusagen als eine frage
ja es ist natürlich auch ein also ich
würde umgekehrt bei mir immer sagen das
ist natürlich einfach auch ein absolut
unverdientes privileg in einem land
geboren zu sein in dem ich friedlich
aufwachsen durfte dafür habe ich nichts
getan
das ist sozusagen ein geschenk und
insofern also wenn man so sagen will es
ist natürlich auch zufall und kontingent
wo man geboren wird man sollte nicht
glauben dass man sich das hier verdient
hätte
was ich interessant von war musste ich
kannte den ausschnitt ja nicht also als
wir gesprochen haben dass sie natürlich
genau das sagen also sie sagen eben auch
genau die kinder hatten keine chance
und es ist fast eine pflicht zu fliehen
als eltern also das fand ich sehr
eindrücklich
in dem moment und ich finde was man auch
noch mal sagen könnte ist gerade bei der
gegenwärtigen diskussion auch in der
schweiz sollte man ja vielleicht auch
noch mal sagen
heimat ist das wovon man ausgeht hat ts
eliot mal gesagt und vielleicht könnte
man eben auch sagen es ist auch nur das
womit sich beginnen aber nicht das womit
sich enden lässt und vielleicht kann man
sagen heimat ist eben das was wir
gemeinsam herstellen müssen also ist
auch was was man es schaffen kann nicht
etwas was schon fixiert und als auch da
ist und das finde ich so inspirieren
wenn man das so hört sie haben eine
kollektive identität promoviert was
heißt das gemeinsam eine identität zu
schaffen dass sie etwas was sehr viele
menschen jetzt bewegt zum beispiel in
deutschland was man sagt da alle diese
menschen kommen wie sollen wir denn
gemeinsam etwas werden auch das ist ja
ein neuer anfang
ja es ist ein und fand ich glaube ja
also ich glaube das ist in der tat auch
ein positiver neuanfang ist ich glaube
man muss natürlich auch wissen die
menschen die da kommen werden auch
vielfach erschöpft sein und sie werden
auch müde sein und manche werden sehr
traumatisiert seien von ihrer erfahrung
also ich würde auch sagen wenn man da
jetzt sagt so und jetzt sollen die
sofort arbeiten und wie sollen jetzt
deutschland also das ist alles richtig
aber ich glaube man muss auch so ein
bisschen sich überlegen wo die herkommen
im sinne von was sie als trauer auch mit
sich mit tragen und gleichzeitig würde
ich sagen schauen sie was ist denn
europa europas immer eine region
einerseits der vielfalt natürlich auch
der widersprüche gewesen es ist immer
eine region übrigens auch der gewalt
auch der ausübenden gewalt also anderen
gegenüber awp dass jetzt die furchtbare
deutsche geschichte ist ob das die show
war ob das die zwei großen kriege waren
ob das die
kolonialkriege waren und natürlich auch
die gewalt in den kolonialstaaten also
ich glaube das ist auch die tradition
europas
man soll jetzt nicht so tun als ob da
jetzt menschen zu uns kommen die
sozusagen besonders mit gewalt verwoben
werden wohingegen wir in europa das gar
nicht kennen also das ist sozusagen auch
etwas beschönigend in den blick auf die
eigene geschichte und gleichzeitig würde
ich sagen das sind menschen die den mut
und die kraft haben aufzubrechen die für
ihre kinder etwas anderes wollen die
wenn man mit ihnen spricht
ich hab das seltene solche bekenntnisse
zu europa zur demokratie zu freiheit und
zum rechtsstaat gehört kein europäer
spricht mehr so wie diese syrischen
flüchtlinge sprechen
also man hat das gefühl die verkörpern
vielmehr die ideale die jetzt
gelegentlich ihnen vorgehalten werden
als ob sie nicht dazu passen ja und
insofern glaube ich es ist auch es ist
natürlich eine aufgabe die auch
schwierigkeiten birgt ja aber ich nehme
die erstmal ist ein geschenk war gibt es
dann natürlich auch ganz andere
sichtweisen es gibt ja auch viele leute
die ängste haben die sagen guck mal als
kompakter frau national es gibt ganz
andere bewegungen in ihren kolumnen
waren sie immer wieder von der angst und
sagen angst ist eigentlich nichts
anderes wiegens und ressentiments was
etwas verdecken will eigentlich
irgendwelche rassistischen vorurteilen
liberalen rassismus nennen sie das ja
also ich würde sagen also natürlich gibt
es dinge über die ich auch nachdenken
die ich mich frage wie sollen die
gelingen also natürlich ist als wenn ich
mir ist die deutschen zahlen anschaue
eine million syrische geflüchtete
natürlich sind das riesige anforderungen
an die schulen ans gesamte
bildungssystem auf dem wohnungsmarkt
aber eigentlich sind das fragen bei
denen wir sagen würden die gab es schon
vorher
wir sind auch vorher vielleicht versäumt
worden also es geht glaube ich
grundsätzlich darum dass wir
jetzt investieren müssen ich würde sagen
bildungsfragen wohnungsfrage gebe auch
nicht geflüchtete menschen betreffen
also die sozusagen grundsätzlich
aufpassen dass wir eine soziale
gleichheit behalten dass wir ja eine
bestimmte soziale mobilität und
offenheit behalten
darüber denke ich auch nach also ich
glaube dass das nicht einfach ist ich
glaube dass das große anstrengung bedarf
aber ich glaube dieses ganze gerede von
angst wurde angeblich so fremden kultur
ist ein etikett das ist auch ein
etikettenschwindel hinter dem sich ganz
ganz oft einfach nichts anderes als
fremdenfeindlichkeit und rassismus
versteckt ich bin nun selber homosexuell
und muss wirklich mit grosser ja also
mit großem humor feststehen wer auf
einmal jetzt sich alles um die rechte
von schwulen und lesben schert in dem
moment in dem es sozusagen geflüchtete
gibt die hineinkommen denen man
unterstellt sie seien alle
frauenfeindlich sie seien alle
undemokratisch und sie hätten alle was
gegen die rechte von schwulen und lesben
er kenne sei es werden im moment werden
anforderungen an geflüchtete gestellt
die sollte man insgesamt stellen wir
sind alle richtig also sozusagen
getrennt nun wirklich verfechterin von
humanistischen tradition und dem
rechtsstaat und demokratie aber dann
macht mit päda und da machen mir die
rechtspopulistischen parteien ob in
frankreich oder in deutschland oder in
der schweiz sehr viel mehr sorgen als
menschen die fliehen weil sie nicht
genug rechte zugesichert bekommen
sprechen sie noch einmal über diese
menschen diesen respektiv über ihre
arbeit sind begleiten ja immer wieder
ganz viele menschen oder sind in
kriegsgebieten unterwegs sprechen mit
diesen menschen und schreiben darüber
eines baums zu diesem thema weil es sagt
bahr ist überzeugen schafft und
gerechtigkeit und darin sagen sie ja
auch es gibt so was wie eben diese
ethische last der zeugenschaft das was
sie
gibt ihnen offenbar eine ethische last
ja also ich bin aber sie gibt also
natürlich wenn man mit menschen spricht
die geflohen sind wenn man mit menschen
spricht die opfer waren von furchtbarer
gewalt geht es ja erst mal schon darum
dass sie einen überhaupt ihre geschichte
an vertrauen also dass sie nach all den
erfahrungen die sie gemacht haben
überhaupt glauben dass es sich lohnt mit
jemandem zu sprechen überhaupt glauben
dass jemand sie als mensch warnen der
ihnen zuhören möchte und ich empfinde
das erst mal als ein sehr großes aber
auch sehr zerbrechliches geschenk dieses
vertrauen dass mir menschen ihre
geschichte erzählen
diese geschichten muss man aber eben
auch ja einerseits mit den behutsam
umgehen und gleichzeitig muss es einem
als autorin aber auch gelingen sie gut
zu erzählen und das heißt die ethische
lasst die darin liegt ist das einerseits
man eben tatsächlich zeugnis ablegen
muss für jemand anderen das ist ja nicht
meine geschichte sondern die von jemand
anderem und ob mir das gelingt
ob ich das angemessen darstellen nicht
eine ungeheure last die nobelpreisträger
für literatur aus dem jahr 2015 sehr
kleiner alexijewitsch die hat ja auch
bücher geschrieben die in dieser art
vorgehen eines der ganz ganz berühmten
bücher porträtiert menschen die
tschernobyl überlebt haben und da
beschreibt ja auch dass die sagt die
meisten beginnt eigentlich damit zu
erzählen in dem was sie sagen darüber
kann man nicht sprechen
wie gehen sie damit um ja also die
meisten also in manchmal muss ich sagen
die meisten beginnen damit dass sie
sagen schreibst du das auf also wieder
und wieder egal in welcher region egal
in welchem ort der welt bieten einen
menschen darum ihre geschichte
aufzuschreiben und das heißt es gibt
dann erstmal ein unglaublich großer
wunsch dass also einerseits überhaupt
zählen und das ist aufgehoben wird also
ich glaube das sind
vor allem menschen denen ja ihre
subjektivität geraubt worden ist ihr
menschsein negiert worden ist und dass
überhaupt jemand da ist und sagt ja ich
schreibe das auf das was dir widerfahren
ist ist nicht gleichgültig in der welt
das ist glaube ich das erste was dem so
wichtig ist und dann in der tat sagen
sie ganz ganz oft ich weiß gar nicht wie
ich das erzählen sondern die meisten
geschichten sind nicht linear erzählt
sondern menschen springen rückwärts es
gibt lücken oftmals nähern sie sich
einem besonders schmerzlichen ereignis
oder einer besonders schmerzhaften
erfahrung und stoppen dann können da
nicht hin
und das heißt man muss sehr sehr
geduldig sein und lange abwarten und zu
hören und natürlich auch immer wissen
dass was unwahrscheinlich klingt oder
das was um vernünftig klingt oder das
was wirklich ist möglicherweise trotzdem
eine extrem präzise repräsentation von
gewalt sie beschreiben ja auch dass die
meisten so was suchen die ein
referenzsystem an dem das was sie erlebt
haben wieder fest macht festgemacht
werden kann
sie schreiben zb ein kosovo albaner
gefordert wurde und der ihnen dauernd
immer wieder erzählt von seinen neuen
schuhen die ja vor der volcker noch
gekauft habt also der versuch normalität
herzustellen in den grauen ja es ist
ganz oft versuchen also psychologen
nennen das kolping strategien es gibt
seien verschiedene strategien natürlich
zu versuchen diese an normalen
situationen zu integrieren
das ist ja muss man dazu sagen ja nicht
nur eine physische frage ob man solche
schmerzen aus hält das ist auch eben
nicht nur eine moralische frage was da
geschieht sowas ist auch eine kognitive
frage also es ist auch kognitiv das
beschreiben alle
opfer die in konzentrationslagern
gewesen sind beschreiben immer diesen
moment das ankommen ist und nicht
verstehen können was da was also was da
geschieht und das heißt es ist auch ein
kognitives problem überhaupt erst mal
verstehen zu können dass man auf einmal
in solche entrechteten situationen
hineingeworfen ist und diese geschichte
mit dem kosovo albanern die sie erwähnen
war eben deswegen war symptomatisch weil
er immer mehr sagt ich hatte ganz neue
schuhe und sie waren 200 mark wird und
ich wusste man nicht was er mit diesen
schuhen erzählen wollte und ich glaube
worum es ging war er wollte auch noch
die person sein die er gewesen war bevor
er gefoltert wurde er wollte auch noch
jemand sein der sich solche schuhe
leisten konnte der überhaupt schuhe
trägt am ende ist er eben furchtbar
misshandeln zusammengeschlagen
blutüberströmt barfuß zurück nach
deutschland gekommen und ich glaube das
ist eine eine eine sehr typisches
beispiel für menschen die eben versuchen
an etwas festzuhalten
also irgendeine form von kontinuität
herzustellen zudem leben vor dieser
geschaffen sie das persönlich sie
erleben solche geschichten sind
unterwegs in regionen die ich vermutlich
noch viel schlimmer aussehen wie im
ausschnitt den wir jetzt gesehen haben
und danach sitzen sie in berlin und
trinken cappuccino
da kann ja was natürlich nicht aber also
ich muss dazu sagen syrien war ich nie
also das ist jetzt ich kenne mich da
speziell jetzt nicht aus aber ja die
grundsätzliche erfahrung natürlich die
kenne ich dieses dass man aus gegenden
kommt die sehr zerstört und sehr
verwahrlost und der schmerzlich sind und
dann kommt man plötzlich in so eine
normalität wieder zurück ich denke
manchmal man braucht sowas wie eine
quarantäne also als ob man so zwei
wochen haben könnte in denen man erst
mal keine menschen trifft und so sich
wieder stabilisiert
keinen menschen sprechen darüber
sprechen hilft ja nee ich habe manchmal
das gefühl dass man selber auch auf raub
innerlich also dass man über diese
gegenden eben auch empfindlicher oder
oder erschöpfter oder e-mails ein
bisschen aufgeraut ist und ich habe das
gefühl man muss sich dann erst das handy
wieder so nicht rein gerufen aber so ein
bisschen ja eben langsamer ankommen
das sprechen hilft auch nur bedingt also
man muss auch sagen man sprengt jede
heitere abendessens unterhaltung wenn
man sagt wo man gerade war oder biester
aussah oder wie es darauf also das geht
auch nur in maßen ich finde auch als man
muss jetzt nicht auch jedem dauernd
immer irgendwie auch ein schlechtes
gewissen machen oder damit belasten
diese geschichten zu erzählen das heißt
ich glaube man findet dann über die
jahre natürlich auch so ein
freundeskreis der an da schützt oder
aufhebt oder wo man dann seine form
findet wann man spricht und wann man ja
eher ruhig ist
ich muss sagen im moment schreibe ich ja
vor allem bücher
insofern ist das natürlich auch eine
form also diese erfahrungen von all den
jahren zu verdichten
und sich dabei vielleicht auch so ein
bisschen böse eine katalysatorfunktion
einstellt viele viele reportagen
geschrieben haben wurden ja auch
ausgezeichnet und sie sind auch eine
gefragte expertin dem darum geht darüber
zu berichten wie funktioniert
beispielsweise kriegs schon an das muss
man geht es aber auch kritische stimmen
beispielsweise hat ja und fleischwaren
sie im spiegel kritisierten gesagt sie
würden so was betreiben die produkte
polen eine perfide art des betroffenheit
schon an ich muss den leuten den
eindruck gäbe man ließ damals eine
geschichte von carolin emcke und dann
geht es schon besser wenn man hat
sozusagen sein moralisches sei schon
erfüllt durch die lektüre
was machen sie mit solchen vorwürfen die
vorwürfe kannst du ja nur also da fragt
man sich stimmen sie doch stehen sie
nicht in dem fall ich weiß nicht also
ich finde da gehört eine gehörige
portion zynismus dazu entweder
diejenigen zu kritisieren die solche
arbeit machen oder diejenigen die sie
ganz nehmen und darüber nachdenken steht
jedem frei ist das nicht zu lesen
sozusagen
für mich stellt sich die frage nicht
also ich finde in dem moment in dem man
auf reisen ist und in diesen ländern
unterwegs und menschen trifft die solche
erfahrungen gemacht haben stellt sich
überhaupt gar nicht die frage ob das und
das ist nicht gut da geht es nur darum
wie macht man das und was für eine form
findet man und natürlich sind das dann
auch ästhetische fragen also natürlich
muss man auch entscheidungen treffen
darüber was muss man darstellen was kann
man darstellen was hält man zurück was
wäre obszön was wäre nicht obszön
da muss ich jetzt eigentlich eher sagen
dieser ewige vorwurf es würden diese
berichte sind aufgesetzt oder man man ja
man würde mehr weil er krieg
dramatisieren da würde ich immer sagen
kinder
es ist so viel schlimmer als alles was
in der berichterstattung hier ankommt
also da würde ich immer eher denken es
ist sehr sehr viel abgemilderter
zurückgenommen
behutsamer beschrieben als der eindruck
den man vor ort hat also insofern es
gibt nach geschichten die sie nicht
erzählen ja klar sowieso also erstens
gibt es sehr sehr viel mehr was ich
recherchiert habe was nie eine
geschichte kommt es gibt natürlich auch
relativ viel erfahrungen wo man jemandem
hilft wo man aktiv wird wo man was tut
worüber man nie schreibt
und es gibt natürlich dauernd die
entscheidung oder die frage
erstens worauf konzentriert man sich
welche geschichten erzählt man sind es
unbedingt immer die dramatische rennen
sozusagen die man erzählen muss oder
erzählt man möglicherweise die kleineren
sucht man schon die allein die frage auf
welche figuren mann oder menschen man
sich konzentriert suche ich die menschen
aus die ja besonders exzentrisch oder
extremistisch oder besonders fremd
erscheinen oder such ich von euch die
stilleren die leiterin die gebrochene
figuren aus und also da weiß ich wofür
ich mich entscheide
aber ich glaube das sind natürlich
fragen die man sich ob man schreibt oder
ob man im fernsehen arbeitet dauern
stellen muss und wie gehen sie damit um
wenn eine person in sehr nahe kommt und
möglicherweise auch sie um hilfe bittet
ganz konkret und geld oder andere dinge
das kommt merkwürdigerweise nicht vor
also es ist nein also komischerweise
also es kommt immer wieder vor dass
menschen sagen 'bitte schreibst du das
auf aber um geld oder um das ist also
man würde annehmen dass das
und das eigenwillige weise ist glaube
ich die währung die also zum klassischen
so aus dass ich nicht viel zu geben
hätte aber also es gibt natürlich
situationen wo man gerne extrem gerne
helfen möchte und es gibt situationen wo
man auch also in die ganzen tag lang
sich ungenügend fühlt dass ich war
beispielsweise auf haiti nach dem großen
erdbeben
wenn über ein jahr hinweg immer wieder
hingefahren habe seine
langzeitbeobachtung gemacht und da würde
man natürlich einfach viel lieber gerne
zimmer seien dann schreiner sein und
einfach mal irgendeine hütte aufbauen
können und also das heißt natürlich hat
man dauernd das gefühl von ungenügend
aber also für mich kommt jetzt geld
geben überhaupt gar nicht in frage
nicht nur bei der frage ob man es hätte
oder ob man es nicht hätte sondern weil
ich glaube dass es das in einer weise
die beziehung zu den menschen die man
dann spricht so überlagert mit
misstrauen dass ich nicht mehr sicher
sein kann warum mir jemand etwas erzählt
ob der eine dem nächsten erzählt die hat
mir geld gegeben erzählt der auch was
dann kriegst du auch geld ich recht also
für mich ein absolutes tabu
und das heißt jetzt nicht dass man nicht
gemeinsam was essen kann oder ein essen
teilt oder soja aber aber es ist auch
nicht die grunderfahrung die
grunderfahrung ist dass die menschen
wollen dass man sich mit ihnen hinsetzt
und die geschichte auch schon weil es
sagt ist der titel dieses buches ist die
tatsache dass etwas sagt bahr ist auch
fast schon ein imperativ ist erzählen ja
also nicht sozusagen es natürlich nicht
für die opfer von gewalt selbst also ich
würde jetzt niemals glauben man könnte
verordnen wann ein traumatisierter
mensch sprechen kann oder sprechen muss
ich finde es nur sehr heikel dass ich so
leichtfertig durchgesetzt hat dass man
so spricht das ist unbeschreiblich und
das ist uns sagt ba und
in gewisser hinsicht glaube ich
sakralisierung man damit einerseits
solche geschehen ist auch als man macht
sie zu etwas unberührbaren man kann
nicht darüber sprechen
das ist so furchtbar dass man es auch
eben nicht anrühren darf ich glaube ist
eine bestimmte form auch ein
schutzreflex tut einem auch besser wenn
man nicht dann so ganz genau darüber
spricht oder zu werden muss und ich
glaube eben dass man als gesellschaft
eine ethische pflicht hat geschichten
auch wenn sie schwer zu ertragen sind
und auch wenn die menschen die sie
betreffen vielleicht lange brauchen bis
sie erzählen können dass wir versuchen
müssen trotzdem sie zu bergen und sie
gehören zu unseren gesellschaften dazu
und ich glaube das mindeste dass wir
sozusagen die un- geprügelten oder
verschonten als pflicht haben ist es den
menschen zu ermöglichen dass sie ihre
geschichten uns erzählen können und auch
in der weltliteratur unglaubliche
geschichten die wir die wir brauchen
glaube ich also denken jan primo levi
wir denken die an jean améry menschen
die geschrieben haben über das was sie
erlebt haben und die natürlich
unglaublich wichtige dokumente
abgeliefert haben
dessen ungeachtet fand ich auch ganz
bemerkenswerte ihre eine kolumne wo sie
gesagt haben es geht nicht an dieser
satz man muss doch oder man darf doch
wohl auch noch sagen also gewissen
leuten oder gewissen inhalten sagen sie
dann verbieten sie den mund oder sagen
es geht nicht rein das argument das muss
man doch jetzt wohl noch sagen dürfen
geht dann nicht immer naja also bei
genauem darf man nicht sagen
nein ich glaube bei dem das ist ja eine
das ist ja nicht ein rhetorisches
schutzschild also wer anhebt mit man
wird ja wohl noch mal sagen dürfen
wappnet sich mit diesem satz schon vorab
gegen eine vermeintliche zensur die gar
nicht stattgefunden hat also der satz
kommt immer so daher als würde danach
etwas folgen das unterdrückt sei
als gäbe es keine möglichkeiten also was
auch immer zu kritisieren und meiner
ansicht nach ist es eben einfach eine
art wie gesagt eine art schutzschild mit
dem vorweggenommen wird das danach dann
einfach schäbigste ressentiments kommen
und ihnen ein beispiel geben
ja man wird doch also ich will es gar
nicht aus ich mag gar nicht aussprechen
was dann kommt ja aber ich glaube es
wird sozusagen heutzutage wird eben
rassismus verkleidet als eine als
sozusagen eine meinung die man
verteidigen muss gegen die unterdrückung
sozusagen im öffentlichen raum und erst
natürlich sagen
die gibt's ja gar nicht die
unterdrückung des öffentlichen raums
oder es wird überall dürfen jetzt sagen
leute fremdenfeindliche ansichten aber
ich glaube die frage die wir uns als
gesellschaft stellen müssen ist also
einerseits überhaupt ob es nicht
bedingungen gibt dafür dass ein
zusammenleben miteinander gelingen kann
und da gibt es bedingungen von
höflichkeit von respekt also ganz
einfacher manieren die wir völlig
selbstverständlich finden und dann gibt
es natürlich die frage ob wir im
toleranz tolerieren müssen oder ob bei
ihnen toleranz schluss ist und und dann
ist man selber intolerant also ich habe
ja aber ich glaube aber ich glaube
ehrlich sagt ich finde das gar nichts so
besonderes ich finde gar nicht ich würde
sagen also seit wann ist denn sozusagen
also seit wann ist es denn eine qualität
einen sozusagen exhibitionismus der
kaltherzigkeit zu praktizieren also ich
bin völlig erstaunt über sozusagen das
selbstbewusstsein mit dem wirklich jeder
dreck und jede gemeinheit und jeder
auf menschen neuerdings verteidigt wird
als das ist nun mal irgendwie
meinungsfreiheit
also ich kann nur sagen mir ist das
fremd- und ich finde etwas anderes ob
wir natürlich fragen stellen kritische
nachfragen stellen ob wir sagen wir
wollen sozusagen den rechtsstaat
verteidigen demokratie verteilen gegen
wen auch immer
ja aber einfach nur schäbig
menschenverachtend anderen menschen
eigenschaften im kollektiv zuzuschreiben
kultur alice nennt man das heute oder
man spricht nicht mehr von rassismus
aber kultur alice muss weil man
sozusagen an der kultur eigenschaften
fest was entscheider die ganze gruppe
haben dann das entscheidende finde ich
einfach nur dass man sozusagen nicht
mehr sagt mir gefällt nicht wie du das
und das tust also dass man nicht mehr
handlungen kritisiert oder taten sondern
personen das finde ich schon das erste
problematische und was zweite finde ich
dass wenn einzelnen personen
eigenschaften eines ganzen kollektivs
zugeschrieben werden und diese
eigenschaften unhistorisch und
undynamisch wenn also die bleiben bei
denen ja also muslime sind so und soja
juden sind so unsere frauen sind so und
so ja also wenn wir noch einmal zum
anfang zurück kommen neuanfang alles
beginnt mit der sehnsucht welche
sehnsucht denken sie könnte denn ein
bild sein um eine gesellschaft diese
offene gesellschaft wieder
voranzutreiben ja das ist das ist die
tolle phase die frage ist richtig toll
ich glaube nämlich dass wir genau das
leisten müssen wir müssen glaube ich
eine positive erzählung finden die
attraktiv ist die sozusagen auch lust
darauf macht an ihr teilhaben zu können
und ich sage immer mein bild dafür ist
die kunst der fuge von bach
das gibt eine komposition also von bach
eben die kunst der fuge und sie ist
nicht zu ende geschrieben ja sie ist
offen geblieben und es hat bach nicht
notiert wer sie aufhören sollen also
welche instrumente was für ein
arrangement sein soll und so stelle ich
mir europa vor also es gibt ein skript
es gibt eine komposition sozusagen das
sind die menschenrechte das sind die
bürgerrechte
aber sie ist nicht zu ende geschrieben
und das steht nicht fest wer sie
aufführen wird und das heißt der klang
wird immer wieder anders sein sehr wird
jetzt durch andere menschen anders
klingen
und sie werden diese geschichte in einer
bestimmten weise fortschreiben und
trotzdem bleibt daran noch etwas
sozusagen an diesem original noch zu tun
es bleibt noch was zu tun es gibt
trotzdem sozusagen eine bestimmte form
von schriftlicher begrenzung wenn man so
will das sind eben die grundrechte und
die klinge blumen war vor noch nicht
allzu langer zeit hier am tisch und wer
hat davon gesprochen dass wir wieder
einen gemeinsamen traum brauchen aber es
ist nicht so einfach sich so ein traum
gemeinsam zu erfinden denn die einzelnen
träume in unterschiedliche richtungen
gehen ja wobei ich also ich kann jetzt
nur sagen ich bin so verliebt in europa
immer schon gewesen ich bin als deutsch
natürlich auch wahnsinnig dankbar dass
ich nicht nur deutsche sein muss sondern
auch europäerin sein darf und für mich
bleibt der europäische traum das größte
geschenk das meiner generation geschenkt
worden ist und ich würde sagen jetzt ist
zum ersten mal eine zeit wo wir als
generation auch tatsächlich
herausgefordert sind den zu verteidigen
ich sehe jetzt ehrlich gesagt liegt
weniger bedroht durch die geflüchteten
als sich die rechtspopulistischen
bewegungen also aber ich glaube in der
tat ihre fragen ist ganz wichtig wie
schaffen wir es einerseits an diesem
traum wenn man so will ein bisschen
festzuhalten und ihnen wieder zu
erneuern und zu beleben und sichtbar zu
machen
ja dass man ihn mit dankbarkeit und
demut annehmen kann und nicht mit stolz
und vorurteil
ich danke ihnen frau dankeschön in der
sternstunde kunst nehmen wir sie jetzt
gleich mit auf eine reise in die 19 30er
jahre der aufkommenden faschismus zwingt
die künstler dazu politisch farbe zu
bekennen
bleiben sie dran und sehen sie lieber
dart den fünften teil der abenteurer der
modernen kunst wir sehen uns am
kommenden sonntag wieder dann zu
philosophischen gedanken experimenten
mit richard david precht bis dahin eine
gute zeit
[Musik]